he walks away from the bank the check to
$117,000 what was that about
yeah what she and I went and we found a
house we rented the house she rented the
house and I went with her we walk in the
house she likes it the guy comes in the
investor that owns the house comes in
meets her they he she signs the lease
she gives him some money she rents the
house I go to public records I take the
deed that's in the house from his name
and I put it into her name Rosita Perez
his name and we satisfy the loan that he
had on the house so now she owns a house
Rosita Perez owns the house free and
clear so then we just then we apply for
like five six seven five or six or they
said seven mortgages I wanna say was
five or six but whatever let's say it's
seven who cares she applies for the
loans we scheduled a bunch of loans
where over the next two or three days
she's gonna close on like a million
dollars worth almost a million dollars
with the loans maybe seven on this Jews
house on this guy's house I mean what am
I supposed to say that's what it was I
mean he's gonna be fine he's gonna be
fine eventually the Tyler Tyler
insurance companies will pay it back
that's what always happens
yeah no one feels bad for the insurance
companies anyway okay
this is surveillance footage of Alison
trying to deposit the check I was the
girl that went to the bank and I gave
the check to the Tyler I would say okay
deposit this into my account and then I
would go slowly to pull the money out
week after week supposedly we never got
that far the check wouldn't clear the
bank because the driver's license was
fake yeah you know what Alison we really
have them there hmm okay so here's what
really happened three mm-hmm so here's
what really happened what really
happened was the girl and I'm not gonna
say the girl's name which was the
mortgage broker that worked for me hmm I
wouldn't want to say her name
well cuz she's currently uh works at a
bank okay she she had a friend a girl
that she says [ __ ] her over like oh
she tore up my she was living in her
house she tore up my furniture she cost
me $10,000 you know if you ever want to
use her information I want to get her
[ __ ] up [ __ ] her you know do something
you know this chick's committing fraud
on a daily basis at the mortgage company
too by the way so she's like can you do
I'm like I don't want to do any I want
stealing buddy's identity I'm making the
fake people but she keeps pushing
Alison's pushing so I use her because
she had like 750 credit scores so I was
like okay so I said yeah but this chick
is from New York does she have a
driver's license out here she does no
she just moved here a few months ago she
hasn't even opened a bank account
nothing so she doesn't have a driver's
license issued in Florida I can go and
get and make you one that hasn't been
placed with anybody yet or assigned
anybody and then I can go and I could
open up a bank account I'd been doing it
all my fake people are being are opening
up egg counts using fake fake driver's
license numbers so I can make one for
her and it will be fine hmm so when we
put it on the license the Alison goes
and opens up a bank account and the bank
account it gets flagged because turns
out that the girl had Oh had gotten a
driver's license which I didn't know
about cuz I was told she didn't have one
so she did get a driver's license in
Florida she had it did
one sign she was so when she walked in
she gave her a different number it
wasn't the same number that showed up in
ChexSystems they said boom there's this
fraud something's wrong so she wasn't
able to open the bank account but that's
not even the main issue the main issue
was that she went to one title company
closed the title got the money
the next closing she went to the woman
at the title company looked at her
license and went this doesn't look like
you it was her it was her license it was
her picture I had her dye her hair black
and curl it and go in and get a DMV
photo and do the whole thing it was
really her picture but a couple days
before the closing she dyed her hair
blonde and we were like what the [ __ ]
are you doing and she's like no it's
still my picture and we're like you're
Rosita Perez you're Spanish [ __ ] the
very least you can yeah you can say that
you were married but you still wide why
change your hair's black on the picture
and so she's all she's like it's not a
big deal and what's the problem oh my
god you're overreacting so she goes in
boom second closing the chick the woman
that the title companies like this
something doesn't make sense has her
sign all the documents but won't give
her the check Wow so that's what really
happened was then she goes in the bank
she can't open the bank account then she
gives the cheque to a buddy of mine
who's running a similar scam in Orlando
and it's been flagged so now it's been
flagged that's what what really happens
they streamline it okay
thanks but none will take it though this
scheme is foiled tox hasn't given up the
dream of doing one big score living the
rest of his days on a beach in the
Caribbean that trees you have like a
certain amount of money in your head
like I'm just gonna hit one big lick and
then I'm moving to the Caribbean is that
true no I really what I I'm and I say
that a in here I just said a million I
just want to get a like a million
dollars and I mean I may have said that
and I did want to get some money you
know I wanted I don't quit I don't think
I had a million dollars because there
were multiple times we had a million
dollars okay you know I'm saying so it
doesn't but a lot of times you have to
understand - if we had five million or
three million dollars out well we owe
four million
didn't [ __ ] mortgages are four
million dollars in real estate
you see I'm saying it's like you never
really have that money exact cash it's
always equity right Matt was the most
greedy person out there and what he
wanted was money money money money he
didn't care who he hurt who he stepped
on or what he had to do in order to get
it nice so listen man I color right now
so I was watching this in when I was
with Triana and Mike at the gym when I
she said that I'd been talking to Alison
in the halfway house right the whole
time
so I picked up the phone and I called
her right then right then and I went
Matt is the greediest person I've ever
met in my entire life and she goes you
don't understand they interviewed me for
hours they chopped it up it's not like
that
it's not like what you said and she's
like you know I'm so stupid
I was trying to get my sentence reduced
you don't look good laughing I was like
I don't care oh my god what's funny
though Cox and Alison breakup and Cox
goes looking for another woman to play
money to his Clyde charming but in the
beginning told me how much he cared
about me and loved me and what you know
did with us to get a place together
Rebecca Hawke is another single mom
who's fallen under the spell
another single mom her story does not
have a happy ending but it begins with
promise all of his friends watch a brand
new cars gorgeous homes I mean I'm
thinking I'm barely making a sure I'm a
single mom but why have a quote Matt Cox
is an unlikely ladies man he's
diminutive to me think what she says you
mean so look so the guy that we stole
the house rumor we got the house from
here's a quote from him in the book is
at the beginning of each chapter I but
here's a quote I put and his name was a
Steven Jackson real-estate investor he
put it's almost impossible to stop them
when they're this talented and smart
[Laughter]